sie haben wie viel Tage im polizeige war
es am verbracht insgesamt
waren es wahrscheinlich sieben oder acht
Tage ja in Isolation ja Einzelhaft
und Sie Verständnis dafür also es sagt
ihnen ja das ist da ein Problem mit dem
Gesetz gibt
ich möchte aber wirklich sagen dass es
friedliche Proteste sind und dass sie
auch einen großen Teil so wahrgenommen
werden also wenn ich zum Beispiel mit
der Polizei in Kontakt bin dann wird das
als friedlich wahrgenommen und auch mit
anderen Menschen auch auf der Straße
gesehen also ich provoziere ja nicht
aktiv Gewalt es kommt sicherlich zu zu
Gewalt Ausbrüchen also das haben wir ja
gesehen das haben wir gerade gesehen
sicherlich auch sicherlich Sie dafür
Verständnis also wenn ich in diesem
Prozessen sondern bin ich demütig
klingen wenn der Mensch auch aggressiv
auf mich zukommen ich kann natürlich
verstehen dass der Mensch ist
[Musik]